the new york attorney general announced
yesterday that after an investigation
it has been determined that governor
cuomo is a serial
sexual harasser which i think we already
kind of knew but they did a full
investigation
and uh did a press conference released
the whole report here is the attorney
general
describing some of their findings let's
watch
the independent investigation has
concluded
that governor andrew cuomo sexually
harassed multiple women
and in doing so violated federal and
state law
specifically the investigation found
that
governor andrew cuomo sexually harassed
current
and former new york state employees by
engaging in
unwelcome and non-consensual touching
and making numerous offensive comments
of a suggestive
and sexual nature that created a hostile
work
environment for women
the investigators independently
corroborated and substantiated these
facts
through interviews and evidence
including
contemporaneous notes and communications
this evidence will be made available to
the public along with the report
okay he created a a hostile work
environment for uh
for women he was sounds like he's just
sort of a pig and a jerk
to women and there's the whole report
was released you could read the entire
report
if for some reason you want to now
governor cuomo
is uh not apologizing he is not backing
down an inch
people are it seems that you know there
are plenty of conservatives
of social media that we're kind of
celebrating and saying he's going down
he's going down for this
he might i'm not ready to say that he
won't
but i wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't put
all my money on it okay i wouldn't i
wouldn't bet
my life savings on this actually
bringing andrew cuomo down
because at the end of the day even if
even if everyone seems to be turning on
him right now the media is turning on
him
his fellow democrats in new york are
he is still at the end of the day a
democrat
and even for andrew cuomo that uh
provide that is a force field that can
protect you from almost anything and
that's why he's taking this approach
rather than apologizing
he uh held up you know he spoke to the
media afterwards
had a televised address did not
apologize
basically accused all these women of
lying
and they also explained he explained
much of this away
by claiming that well he gropes and
manhandles
everyone not just attractive women and
that's supposed to make it all better
let's listen to some of
andrew cuomo here i do it with everyone
black and white young
and old straight
to an lgbtq
powerful people
friends strangers
people who i meet on the street
after the event the woman told the press
that she took offense at the gesture
and for that i apologize
another woman stated that i kissed her
on the forehead
at our christmas party and that i said
ciao bella now i don't remember doing it
but i'm sure that i did i do
kiss people on the forehead i do kiss
people on the cheek
i do kiss people on the hand
i do embrace people i do hug
people men and women
i do on occasion say ciao bella on
occasion
i do slip and say sweetheart
or darling or honey i do
banter with people i do tell jokes
some better than others i am the same
person in public
as i am in private yeah well that's part
that's part of the problem there uh
cuomo because you're a horrible person
in public
so hey guys i'm horrible in public what
did you expect
i mean that is in some ways a kind of
oddly powerful argument i suppose
but this this is this is his response
and if you're just listening to the
audio podcast
you might have missed the slideshow that
he assembled and put together
where he was talking about all the
people that he gropes and then there was
a slideshow of him groping
people of all different races
ethnicities creeds
and so on look i grope everyone okay
and no one is safe from me i'll i'll i
will i will grope and touch anyone black
white young old
the postman the cashier at home depot
the disabled humans animals
if space aliens landed here i would
grope them too in a heartbeat
it's what i do that's his defense
uh and it was surprisingly not very
convincing or compelling
to a lot of people though again it
doesn't mean that he's actually going to
suffer any real consequence for this
whatsoever
and he's obviously not gonna step down
himself his his uh he's wagering on the
fact that he's a democrat and he can
ride this one out
and he's probably right about that now
as far as the accusations themselves i
did read a little bit of the report
and at least some of the sort of summary
summaries of the findings
and some of what he's accused of doing
is
clearly clearly goes beyond being merely
inappropriate
he's accused in some cases of grabbing
women
under underneath their shirts and so on
there's like sex that is
sexual assault that goes beyond sexual
harassment
that's that's the accusation anyway but
then it is also odd
when when you have claims like that
okay that's sexual harassment or rather
that's sexual assault
but then in the report they also include
things like
uh he he has he referred to some women
as single mamas
and another point called them mingle
mamas whatever whatever that means
uh he said at one point he was talking
to some female assistant or something
and he said that uh
he really wants to take a woman on a
motorcycle ride
into the mountains i don't know if
that's some kind of euphemism or if he
actually just
literally just wants to go to the
mountains on a motorcycle whatever it is
but those kinds of calling someone a
single mama
that's kind of weird be arguably
inappropriate
if they're your employee but it's not
illegal i
wouldn't even call that sexual
harassment in fact i would i would not
call that sexual harassment
so you're kind of lumping that stuff in
with
what would be if it actually happened
straight up
straightforward sexual assault
and so that raises some questions though
i don't doubt that the guy's a creep
and yet i put all this to the side
because all of this
pales in comparison to the fact that
andrew cuomo
killed thousands of elderly people
and he did kill them he consigned them
to their death
he signed their death warrants okay he
locked them
in nursing homes with people that he
knew to be infected by this virus
that primarily kills the elderly in
nursing homes
okay he he locked them in a room with a
with a with a
with a bomb and lit the fuse
so it's it's hard for me to care about
sexual harassment
complaints it's hard for me to muster
any real outrage about this
given that he again killed thousands of
elderly people
when i think of of andrew cuomo and the
terrible things that he's done
that will to me always be the first
thing that comes to mind and i don't
really need to think about anything else
so if he does go down for for this the
sexual harassment
[Music]
what what will it say about our culture
that this is what brings him down
that he could murder thousands of
elderly people and suffer no consequence
for
remember this was known the nursing home
scandal was known
when he was still
being hailed as a hero across the
country especially by the media
and he got the big book deal and he went
on a book tour
and you had people in the media even men
like trevor noah
describing themselves as homosexuals
that happened
after we knew about him condemning
thousands of elderly people to
a horrible death so he suffered no
consequence for that at all and that
might be understating in fact he was
celebrated for that
um and then it comes out that he made
inappropriate comments to women in the
workplace and
made an uncomfortable workplace
environment for women as the attorney
general says
and that's the thing that makes people
go whoa whoa
whoa hang on a second this crosses a
line here
hold on wait a second okay you kill
you kill uh thousands of elderly people
that's one thing we can overlook that
but you called a woman a single mama no
sir
we can't accept that
is totally demented and deranged
that this is the thing now i know you
could say
well they're both bad and we could be
upset about both
yes they're both bad but one
is on a totally different plane when
you're talking about
mass murder as opposed to what is
mostly inappropriate comments
now there were again a few accusations
of actual physical contact being made
but most of the accusations are about
inappropriate comments
and this is being called a sexual
harassment scandal after all
even by the media so you've got
inappropriate comments down here and
then up here you've got mass murder
yeah they're both bad but but i can't
make equal space
in my heart to be equally outraged by
both
i'm so outraged by the mass murder that
it doesn't
the sexual harassment claim it's it's
there's there's no room for that
in terms of of my outrage
you know uh john wayne gacy murdered
dozens of young men and when i think
about john wayne gacy
that's what comes to mind that's like
all i need to know about him
it may be true in fact i wouldn't be
surprised if you told me that he was
also rude
to his next door neighbor and made
inappropriate comments but it would just
seem weird if you said hey
john wayne gacy yeah he he he murdered
you know 30 young men
he also made inappropriate comments to
his next door neighbor and we could be
upset about both you know
[Music]
we can but
how can you even put those two things in
the same sentence is my question
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content